[Music]
earlier this week we had to make a
difficult decision to put down our dog
of mika who is 14 and a half years old
and she is the last of the dogs some of
you may remember the video with magnus
our other dog who we had to put down
about a year and a half ago so this is a
video that's kind of a tribute to
somebody who was a big part of our life
here this video is pretty long because
there was a lot of time in fact 10 years
that we got to spend together as part of
what my wife calls our four-legged
family and with Amica passing now we're
down to just one member of that sassy
the cat who you'll see in just a bit
Magnus who you see here with Amica when
they were both quite young was Micah's
older brother and helped to pick her out
and they were more or less inseparable
two different types of dogs both black
lab mixes but Magnus with flat core
retriever to make it with cataluña
Leopard hound and two different
personalities but very close with each
other and as you can see in these
pictures mostly from Kingston where we
lived they spent a lot of time hanging
out with each other and engaging with
each other
Emiko was a pretty cool dog and you can
kind of get a sense of just how powerful
she was she was 110 pounds at her peak
looking at her arms and legs here in
this picture when she was young she was
a dog of incredible energy as you can
see her here tearing I think it's a old
shirt apart you know just for play and
then soon you can see her also
at play with here we go Baxter the
landlords or neighbor's dog who she
really liked spending time with after
she got used to him and we called them
the three amigos actually her and Magnus
and Baxter you see her playing fairly
gently and then here comes Magnus
checking things out getting himself into
the mix in just a little bit and they're
doing what we call mouth fencing Magnus
wanting to get involved in and now
Baxter is trying to stir some things up
with Magnus who's over there and those
three would spend a lot of time with
each other playing around enjoying
themselves lounging
[Music]
[Music]
I mentioned our four-legged family and
there were four members to that you can
see all of them here on the bed Amica
and magnus and then the two cats who
were both sisters the older ones rescued
from a fire Sassie who we still have and
teensy teensy is the one who's a little
bit compressed behind the pillow and now
here's some other shots of them all
together hanging out this was something
that they would do quite frequently they
had spent a good part of the day just
laying around together here's a Mika
playing with Baxter who's trying to get
her interested in the ball that he has
[Music]
those three would often spend a lot of
time together out in the yard here you
can see that I'm just hanging out in the
sunlight and then here's them playing
one of their favorite games three-way
tug-of-war which sometimes Amica would
get into and sometimes not one of her
favorite toys back then were these big
heavy Kong's that you could throw around
the yard and you'll see her now hustling
with Magnus all over one of them
[Music]
[Music]
tug-of-war was also a very favored
indoor sport as well as you can see here
an Magnus would pull her back even
though he was lighter than her he had
greater jaw strength and I think
leverage can make us a little bit
bemused at this point
[Music]
New York winters would dump a lot of
snow into the yard and you can see them
hanging out and playing in the snow and
then afterwards
[Music]
Magnus and I would blaze the trails
Anamika would follow behind because she
wasn't quite as good at getting around
in the snow as he was sometimes you see
him kind of punking her trying to get
her to engage with him as their guard
but she she really loved being out there
with him and going wherever the trails
would allow her to so this is kind of a
long clip where you can see just how far
these trails went and how much fun she
would have sniffing around checking
everything out
[Music]
come on pika
[Music]
[Music]
given Mika
[Music]
[Music]
once we moved back here to Milwaukee we
had to take them for walks several times
a day and actually they really enjoyed
the exercise Magnus it was a little bit
of a boss he liked to pull on a Micah's
leash and sort of walk her you can see
him carrying that out here he also went
after his own leash occasionally as he
you see I'm doing here - and Amica very
good-naturedly put up with it I just
seem to faze her too much
it's a Magnus getting quite excited
without the leash we would go walk
sometimes for miles at a time here in
the downtown of Milwaukee going over to
the East Towne area and other parts of
West going down to the Third Ward going
further north here you see something
cool that happened on the Riverwalk and
I think it's it's largely attributable
to Magnus Amica was a Katrina puppy and
was quite afraid of water so going by
the river was a bit of a scary prospect
for her but you notice that she
eventually starts taking an interest in
getting a bit bolder when it comes to
putting herself out there and she did
change quite a bit over time while
Magnus was still healthy enough to take
walks they were pretty inseparable you
see them here in the winter and now you
see them doing one of their favorite
things which was after the farmers
market devouring some of the kettle corn
that was left after the person picked up
his stakes and moved the tent and all of
that sort of stuff they once they
realized that kettle corn was tasty you
couldn't keep them out of it
here's Maddy several years ago helping
to walk them and you knows Magnus sticks
right by Amanda Mika is the one who's
pulling the leash ready to get out in
advance and she was quite a handful to
to try to manage she was still quite big
at that time probably 95 pounds or so
and all muscle
[Music]
here we are again on the Riverwalk and
this time she is watching the Ducks both
her and Magnus quite excited about the
birds and wanting to you know know what
they were she's also become quite
interested in peace in recent years -
[Music]
this is her walking much more recently
you notice the big limp
she had fat tumors that that got in the
way of full range of motion and by this
time she was getting pretty lame in her
back legs both due to you know atrophy
of the muscles and arthritis and perhaps
some neurological stuff but you notice
how happy she is getting out to take a
walk being in the open air she really
had a great spirit
[Music]
we can't really say that she appreciates
Modern Art as such but she was very
interested in this sculpture that was
put outside of the Wisconsin Center
which is diagonal across the
intersection to our apartment building
and yeah when it came in she really
wanted to know what it was Amica was
also an incredibly social dog and you
see her here dressed up in her costume
for a pet Halloween party that we had in
our apartment building she also attended
a party that there were going to be
other pets that she was the first one
there and we think that she thought the
party was particularly for her she went
down there with with our dog walker and
enjoyed herself than we showed up and
you can see how happy it's about
everything going on there
[Music]
she liked being out here in the snow in
our Wisconsin winters you know taking
walks and being out sometimes in the
blustery environment here she's in her
little coat that we got her to wear for
that and you can see the snow blowing at
this time pretty soon you'll start to
see her taking a pause and doing one of
her favorite things in the snow which is
eating snow and she was not always as
picky as we'd like about which snow she
would indulge in at least here it's
relatively clean snow that she's licking
up
[Music]
cigrip you little ice cream
we have a park that's only a block from
our apartment as well and they always
put out Christmas decorations that
people come to take pictures with them
meek is fascinated by things themselves
and probably the smells of other dogs
one of the perks of the place that we
live in is that they put out dog cookies
for dogs at the office no here she is
having some of those and enjoying them
quite a bit quite nice that they do that
here we go more cookies for her
[Music]
[Music]
after having her snack it's time to make
our way to the elevator and get back
upstairs
so that we got settled in after the walk
to the very end she was a very
food-centric dog you can see her here I
think I have a cookie in my hand she's
prancing along you know waiting for her
chance to get it I'll show you now
another thing that she was particularly
known for
[Music]
[Music]
you can do it
what are you doing here I'm carrying
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
we ordered and got a really nice leather
couch very affordably and it didn't take
too long before a meek had decided that
it was her couch even though she wasn't
supposed to be up there on the couch and
you can see here her settled in and then
she also gets caught from time to time
as well
Mika that very supposed to be on the
couch
on the leather couch
you mess things up with your pies
to get there
what do you think
we think Pikachu
oh you're just gonna settle in and take
it easy there
[Music]
are you good girl
are you bad girl kind of girl are you
are you better bad where do you belong
do you belong there on the couch what do
you think
oh look who it is
is that where you're supposed to be
okay you're good girl
you can be on the couch yeah good girl
that's a good girl peekaboo
[Music]
you can share with her don't sit on her
though okay Jesse you can stay
[Music]
what's the matter is he on your couch
did he mistake this for an opportunity
for him to nap
get him off of there
tell them what you want
okay that was nice get up move it
[Music]
work
[Music]
bingo
[Music]
this is one of the last times that she
was able to get herself up onto the
couch even with some help
after her first seizure which she
recovered from she just wasn't
interested in that
and this was close to the end and I got
here I was thinking about what was
coming before too long
we also used to go out on a couch on the
Sun Deck that our apartment complex has
and we'd go for a walk and then come in
go ahead up there and hang out on the
couch she really enjoyed being out there
and doing that so quite nice to hang out
there with her hears us out at one of
the local dog parks you can tell she's
not walking all that well and she can't
run very much anymore but she still
enjoyed being outside and getting to see
other dogs and hanging out so that was
one of the last times that we were out
there and she's just kind of following
along if it were when she was younger
she would have been tearing around you
know you probably wouldn't even be able
to track her that easily with the camera
I mentioned she was a really food
oriented dogs you can see her in our
elements and this shot
I'm gonna try and knock stuff out of
there
never eating your line called notes
like hey what the hell here like cookies
but they're not
okay in the north
oh you're burying for later not sure
about nope Oh
okay down the hill
[Music]
yes
place into the salad
[Music]
but about the no key here like it smells
so much better and yet
you gonna give pan to the donkey before
you stuff it's not buried enough huh
visible
[Music]
don't you try to eat one
I'm gonna eat one of those guys
no you're still married it's really
buried oh oh oh we did not like that
maybe we do like it what do you think
yeah she hid in her mouth
well we may come back to it hard to say
do you need a hand with your notes
do you think any intern okey okay looks
like super buried yep
are you eating it nope you're like
looking and eating it
oh that is not a happy mouth face oh I
don't know think you like it
she also liked to watch TV from time to
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she and sassy the cat became very close
friends particularly after Magnus died
and here you can see that hanging out
together in a lot of different places
they enjoyed napping together and the
still enjoying each other's company here
[Music]
they're drinking water together just
hanky Oates
side by side sassy for some reason
really likes eating dog kibble more than
her own food and here you can see both
of them enjoy a little snack together as
well
[Music]
[Music]
towards the end she really couldn't walk
all that far but every once in a while
she would get a burst of energy and
decide she was going to take me for a
walk instead of following behind me and
here's one case where she is deciding to
walk down Michigan Avenue and we're
seeing where she wants to go
you don't want to go home
on a roll
[Music]
is it you what let's go home come on
come on baby girl
where we going down
[Music]
is this your block are you ready okay
what did you find over here
[Music]
she couldn't go very far most times but
fortunately it's spring and there's
grass for her to gnaw on what she
enjoyed quite a bit strength was really
diminished but she could still snap
twigs and she can tell how much she
enjoys that
Amica was a really great dog and I am
very happy that I got to spend as much
time with her as I did there no none of
us expected her to last this long and to
be in good spirits for nearly all of
that time particularly after her brother
was put down a year and a half before
her so yeah that's really all I have to
say about Amica I'm gonna miss her a lot
and so is everybody else in our
household